si vraiment on avait compté sur les
aides que de l'état il serait déposée
depuis très très longtemps
[Musique]
charge furieuse et qu'on ne peut pas les
honorer on a dit des difficultés à payer
les loyers l'électricité
on a eu très très peur avec ma maman
parce qu'avec mon avance à cinq ans six
ans bientôt qu'on se bat parce que c'est
quand même dur la nouvelle restauration
ont pas tous les joueurs pour monter
mais une boîte qui tient on aurait pu
tout perdre ce qu'on a bâtie en cédant
pour 15 jours de retard de traitement
[Musique]
en effet au mois de décembre ils ont
annoncé des aides qui tombaient autour
de 8
pas de soucis au mois de décembre s'est
directement tomber autour du 8
il s'est avéré que au mois de janvier
déjà on ne pouvait pas faire la demande
d'eads avant le 15 janvier
or déjà ctd catastrophique et puis les
délais très courts les deux les
traitements a touché une veyron one more
thing
quand la dgesip la direction des grapo
nous répond oui mais ça va prendre
encore quelques jours et quelques
semaines
est-ce qu'il se rend compte de ce que
ces quelques semaines pourra l'exercer
pour un restaurant
[Musique]
où
et des personnes qui ont inventé des
numéro siret qui ont inventé des bilans
comptables qui ont réussi à soutirer
l'argent à l'état alors qu'ils en or
devait pas d'argent qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait l'état ils ont fait payer les gens
honnêtes à cause des gens malhonnêtes en
disant à 7.2 ya eu des fraudeurs on va
tous vérifiés manuellement pour qu'on
ait entre 200 et 300 mille
établissements en france
je vous laisse imaginer le temps que ça
peut prendre deux traités manuellement
chaque demande
[Musique]
oh
au moins hawke's bay du sens est pour
moi plus rien n'a de sens c'est eux qui
nous font faire mais c'est eux qui nous
décident qu'ils décident de ne pas nous
faire travailler
donc c'est à eux maintenant d'assumer
pleinement leurs décisions
[Musique]